[Music]
and for a member of the miami heat
myers leonard my brother joined the
marine corps
because of 9 11. when he left for the
first time i remember feeling scared and
lost because he was like a father figure
to me
our father's birthday was 9 11. he
passed when i was six
this day is never easy god bless america
myers-leonard joins us from orlando
tonight
and i really truly appreciate you taking
the time because i know it's
i know it's a tough day on on different
fronts for you but take me through
um what 9 11 meant to you as
you were i guess nine years old at the
time
your older brother bailey was 11.
and how this led him into joining the
marines
well obviously this day for me is very
emotional
it just hits me in a different way and
also it's a very tragic day in united
states history
you know so many innocent lives were
lost and
it also took us to war but
like you said and as i mentioned in that
tweet my brother joined the united
states marine corps
because of 911 and my deep connection to
the military because of my brother
and for many others who i'm very close
with is why this day
means so much to me and as the miami
heat tweeted
you know we should always continue to
honor those people and the first
responders
and everyone involved because there are
many many families who are
still mourning the losses of their loved
ones and that's why
this day is is often very very difficult
for me
and also it's my father's birthday who
passed when i was young
but we stay strong we continue to move
forward
i know that uh it was more than a big
brother little brother relationship with
bayley
uh as you mentioned kind of a father
figure uh
for you and i hope it's okay that we
bring him into this conversation
myers from your hometown of robinson
illinois
surprise again little brother i'm here
thank you you're welcome i love you
bailey you tell me you tell me what your
little brother means to you
and what uh and what this day means to
you as a member of the
united states marine corps
my little brother
i'll tell you what he may be about eight
inches taller than me
bigger than me but
i respect my younger brother
more than almost anybody else who walks
on this planet
i really do for the things he does
off the court for one carrying himself
in the highest regard
and not wanting
not wanting anything extra for the
actions he takes
just for being a good person i mean that
100 percent
with every fiber of my being
my little brother is a good person he
has a good heart
he has no malicious intent towards
anybody
no matter their color creed religion
he does it to help people and that's the
bottom line
myers i just want to give you a lot of
credit because y'all thought you were so
passionate and eloquent when you were
talked about why you were standing for
the national anthem
and that took some tremendous courage i
just want to say thank you for carrying
yourself your brother just said it with
great respect and dignity because i know
there's a lot of pressure
on players today but but for you to
hold your ground and say your peace i
just want to commend you on that
chuck thank you very much i have to say
that your words uh
certainly mean a lot to me you know
obviously a lot of people
watch you guys and and they listen when
you guys speak
and leading up to my decision to stand
for the anthem
caused a lot of heartache because
i know what the military means to me and
what my brother means to me and
the fact that he put you know his life
on the line
um two tours in afghanistan and so
i spoke with many teammates you know i
spoke with miami heat organization i
spoke to the people who i'm close with
and many many members of the military
obviously including my brother
and it wasn't an easy decision because i
truly do
understand and see what is going on in
america right now
it is it's sad and it's wrong
and i truly do live my life to respect
others and love everyone that's how i
was raised
that's who i am and having been around
african-american culture for many many
years because of the aau circuit
all the way through high school into
college and now the nba i've seen
teammates
be impacted by this i've seen their
families be impacted by these things
and it hurts me
but at the same time i always or i tend
to
base my decisions on real life
experience
and the real and raw emotion that i feel
when i hear that anthem and i think
about my brother bailey
sending me photos back home when he was
away
and not knowing you know always how he
was doing
that is raw emotion to me and
i'm sure that's the same way that many
of my teammates and their families and
many people around this country feel
when there are hateful acts
happening to their people and so that's
why
i felt the need to explain myself and i
feel as though i did
but also i would continue to excuse me
continue to use my platform
um to bring awareness uh to these
situations because i
i truly know that silence is compliance
and i need to speak up i need to be
a powerful voice behind this movement
and
i'm also proud to say that my wife and i
gave a considerable amount of money to
the city of miami
to to primarily african-american
communities because they were absolutely
crushed by voter suppression and coven
and i want to be impactful and show
others that
i'm not only talking about it i'm going
to be about it and so
thank you for saying that chuck you know
and uh both of you guys honestly you
know growing up together
you know you know you're only two years
apart you said how did that relationship
become
dad so to speak for two years apart
you know and and what was the building
blocks of that
and um and how did you prepare because
you've been on two
tours in afghanistan how did you prepare
them for being in
somewhat of a bubble down in orlando
i could first start off by saying that
um you know
growing up we we had our differences you
know we fought we did
that whole thing but i can remember
vividly the day
that bailey was leaving for the marine
corps he hadn't told me because he knew
that he was like a father figure to me
he knew i counted on him for his support
and although i am you know
seven feet tall at the time i wasn't
quite that tall but i've always been
the taller individual he was the one
guarding me in my heart
and i remember looking in the driveway
in some
car that i'd never seen before pulled up
in it and
a gentleman got out of the car and he
came and knocked on the front door well
i was the i was the one in the living
room so i answered it and here comes
bailey walking in the living room with
uh i believe two duffel bags and a
backpack on his back
i'll say where are you going and he said
myers
i've decided that i want to fight for
our country and join the united states
marine corps
now i'm leaving today that was one of
the hardest days of my life
i um i'm already emotional human being
bailey is not you know that's why he's
always been the protector of me
but i just went i remember going to my
room and crying for
i i mean it must have been a minimum of
30 minutes so
he's always been that person for me um
because we have had
hardship but i truly feel as though that
is what's
made us the men that we are and that's
why our bond is so strong
number one thank you for your service uh
yes having uh
my late father was was a marine in world
war ii
uh so the utmost respect i have for you
and